novak djokovic expulsé d'australie la
fin d'un aimant gopio aux politiques
sportifs et judiciaires de deux semaines
vouloir de tennis non bâti n'est canton
était susceptible de représenter un
risque sanitaire selon la cour fédérale
australienne
par cette décision le ce pays
l'australie 7/1 elle-même selon le
président serbe aleksandar vucic le
numéro mondial extrêmement déçu ne
pourra donc pas défendre son titre à
l'open de melbourne qui débute ce lundi
[Musique]
boris johnson sur la sellette le premier
ministre britannique est visé par une
série de scandales des révélations sur
les fêtes clandestines organisée à
downing street en plein confinement ne
passe par me auprès de l'opinion
publique ni au sein de la classe
politique appelle à la démission sur le
pipeline de partout
[Musique]
et
bonjour et bienvenue pour une nouvelle
page d'actualités sur rt france
le pass and i ter remplacée par le passe
vaccinale c'est effectif depuis quelques
minutes on retrouve notre reporter et
c'est el farj devant l'assemblée
nationale
c'est donc la fin du marathon
parlementaire et le pass vaccinale est
donc définitivement adopté
mais oui avec 215 voix pour et 58 contre
ce douzième texte sanitaires depuis le
début de la crise du coville 19 et donc
être définitivement adopté une adoption
qui marque la fin de deux semaines de
marathon parlementaire et ce malgré une
ultime haution de rejet à préalable
défendu cet après-midi par la france
insoumise pour cette dernière la lecture
les députés ont donc rejeté les
amendements qui avait été retenu hier
par le sénat ainsi les restaurateurs et
cafetiers pourront contrôler la
concordance entre l'identité de leurs
clients et le pass vaccinale il faudra
fournir un document officiel avec
photographie c'était le premier point
d'achoppement entre députés et sénateurs
l'autre concerne les sanctions
administratives pour les entreprises ne
respectant pas le télétravail là aussi
les amendements ont été rejetés par lé
député après la promulgation de la loi
il faudra donc à présenter un pass
vaccinale pour accéder à certains
endroits où le pass sanitaire était un
taux obligatoire les 12 et 15 ans eurest
soumis aux passes sanitaire actuelle
noté que la france insoumise a annoncé
sur la chaîne parlementaire que 60
députés allaient saisir le conseil
constitutionnel
merci est elle en direct de l'assemblée
nationale
et à ce propos on écoute le décryptage
de claude bronner médecin généraliste à
strasbourg et vice-président du syndicat
union généraliste et pierre henry bovis
avocats pourraient bien de toute manière
que le vaccin et je m'en remettrai à mon
contradicteur mais on voit bien que le
vaccin aujourd'hui n'empêche pas la
circulation du virus est donc bien que
ce pass accident n'est en réalité qu'un
pas ce qui va permettre de polariser la
société de placer la société dans deux
catégories celles qui seront vaccinés
dans vacciner donc c'est à dire en plus
qu'il ya une atteinte à mon sens sont
plus au secret médical et va empêcher
des personnes vous l'avais dit en
introduction va empêcher des citoyens
d'accéder à des restaurants à des salles
prendre le train et c'est un je ne sais
pas dans quel ceci était quelle société
nous promet le premier aujourd'hui les
politiques qui nous gouvernent
actuellement autant le pass mme
vaccinale aurait été utile il y a
quelques mois parce que la vaccination
des plus à risques est vraiment quelque
chose qu'il fallait faire autant au jour
d'aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup moins
nécessaire mais comme toujours le
politique a souvent un peu de retard sur
le
sur ce qu'il faut faire raisonnablement
est effectivement le gouvernement a fait
le choix de monter au créneau sur ce que
la population pense quand même
majoritairement être une bonne chose et
donc je suis assez d'accord que ce
n'était pas le moment d'obliger tout le
monde à se vacciner parce que tout ce
qui devait être vaccinés le sont en tout
cas la plupart d'entre eux et ceux qui
ne le sont pas et qui devrait l'être
c'est-à-dire les plus âgés ceux qui sont
les plus fragiles ceux qui sont
particulièrement malades s'ils ne le
sont pas aujourd'hui je crains que ce ne
soit pas le pas ce qui les amènera à se
vacciner alors qu'ils devraient aux
pays-bas de nouvelles manifestations ont
lieu aujourd'hui au coeur du
mécontentement des citoyens néerlandais
la situation sanitaire et les mesures de
restrictions jugées parmi les plus
contraignantes d'europe
si premier ministre mark rutte a annoncé
des allègements ont déjà en vigueur pour
certains commerces ou les salles de
sport les bars restaurants au lieu de
culture reste fermé pour le moment et
certains n'applique pas les mesures
décidées par les autorités grégoire
douce et
un bol d'air frais et des sentiments
mêlés confiné depuis le 19 décembre et
après des fêtes de fin d'année passées
sous cloche les néerlandais retrouvent
une atmosphère un peu plus respirable
depuis ce samedi les commerces non
essentiels et les salles de sport sont
autorisés à ouvrir leurs portes jusqu'à
17 heures même chose pour les coiffeurs
ou encore les travailleurs du sexe
c'était une période misérable difficile
on s'occupait en variant les activités
comme le click and collect la livraison
à domicile
la vente vidéo
nous avons fait beaucoup de choses
différentes pour maintenir les revenus
oui mais voilà les restaurants bars et
lieux culturels doivent pour le moment
restés portes closes et ce au moins
jusqu'au 25 janvier pour contester ce
qu'ils estiment être une injustice
certains ont décidé de braver
l'interdiction
nous considérons cela comme une
contestation musique je ne comprends pas
cette décision
si vous allez dans un grand magasin
comme un supermarché ou autre il ya 150
personnes qui se promènent je ne
comprends pas cette terrasse est à
l'extérieur il va avoir une distance
d'un mètre et demi je ne comprends pas
c'est une honte que d'autres endroits
puisse rouvrir comme des coiffeurs des
salons de beauté ce genre de choses ils
peuvent ouvrir alors que les gens sont
plus proches les uns des autres qui s'y
aux pays bas les admissions
hospitalières sont en baisse ces
dernières semaines et les services de
réanimation se désengorge mais les
autorités craignent que la propagation
du variant omicron ne fasse repartir ces
indicateurs à la hausse pour le nouveau
gouvernement fraîchement investi le défi
sera de composer à la fois avec les
exigences sanitaires et les vagues de
contestation qui ébranle le pays depuis
le début de l'hiver
l'autriche ou la vaccination va devenir
obligatoire à partir de février les
récalcitrants seront condamnés à des
amendes comprises entre 600 et 3600
euros en cas de récidive une décision
qui survient alors que 71 5% de la
population dispose actuellement d'un
schéma vaccinal complet toute la semaine
des débats houleux se sont déroulés au
parlement qui examinait ce projet de loi
les relances et une personnes ont
manifesté à vienne contre la mesure
qu'elle accuse de bafouer leur liberté
et pour le chancelier autrichien ce
projet demeure constitutionnel
est viable cela signifie que nous allons
à douter l'obligation de vaccination
comme prévu elle entrera en vigueur
début février graff
et maintenant c'est bien sûr un sujet
très sensible
cela signifie qu'il y à de très
nombreuses facettes à prendre en compte
lorsque l'on met en place une telle
mesure c'est
chaud c'est exactement ce que nous avons
fait
novak djokovic expulsé d'australie c'est
la fin de deux semaines d'un imbroglio
judiciaire politico sportif le joueur de
tennis non vaccinés contre le coc u19
étaient susceptibles de représenter un
risque sanitaire selon la cour fédérale
une décision qui a fait réagir le
président serbe aleksandar vucic jugeant
que l'australie s'est humiliée elle même
le niveau le numéro un mondial
extrêmement déçu ne pourra donc pas
défendre son titre à l'open de melbourne
qui a débuté ce lundi mais dsk qui est
quand même au clair
jeu set et match pour le gouvernement
australien novak djokovic tennisman
numéro un mondial a été prié de quitter
l'australie ce dimanche le natif de
belgrade a vu son visa définitivement
annulée à la veille de l'open
d'australie premier tournoi du grand
chelem de l'année à
one les ordres de la cour sont
premièrement le recours est rejeté aux
frais du demandeur lesquels frais sont à
convenir ou à défaut d'accord à évaluer
deuxièmement les motifs seront publiés à
une date ultérieure
ce dimanche signe la fin d'un feuilleton
mouvementé ces deux dernières semaines
il première fois placé en centre de
rétention le 6 janvier novak djokovic
avait vu la justice australienne stature
sa faveur lundi dernier en ordonnant sa
libération immédiate et alors que le
numéro un mondial commence aussitôt à
s'entraîner le ministre de l'immigration
annonce finalement vendredi l'annulation
de son visa décision validée par la cour
fédérale australienne est saluée par le
gouvernement la cour fédérale
australienne a décidé à l'unanimité de
rejeter la demande de contrôle
judiciaire de monsieur novak djokovic
qui visait à contester la décision du
ministre de l'immigration d'annuler son
visa cette décision d'annulation a été
prise pour des raisons de santé de
sécurité et de bon ordre sur la base de
l'intérêt public je me félicite de cette
décision qui vise à maintenir la
solidité de nos frontières et à assurer
la sécurité des australiens al'inverse
serbe n'a pas caché sa déception de ne
pas pouvoir participer à l'open
d'australie je vais maintenant prendre
un peu de temps pour me reposer
récupérer avant de faire d'autres
commentaires
je suis extrêmement déçu de la décision
qui signifie que je ne peux pas rester
en australie et participer à l'open
d'australie je respecte la décision de
la cour et je coopérerait avec les
autorités compétentes
en ce qui concerne mon départ
d'australie le feuilleton djokovic a
pris une ampleur inattendue au fil des
jours devenu la coqueluche des militants
anti vaccins
le tennisman a été soutenue à travers
plusieurs manifestations dans les rues
de melbourne en serbie le président en
personne est intervenue pour soutenir
celui qui est considéré comme un héros
national en humus qu'ils pensent avoir
humilié djokovic avec ce harcèlement de
10 jours mais ils se sont humiliés
eux-mêmes et djokovic pour retourner
dans son pays la tête haute et regarder
tout le monde dans les yeux en lice pour
devenir le tennisman le plus titré de
l'histoire novak djokovic je vois son
rêve de records retardé mais ce n'est
pas tout en se faisant expulser
d'australie le serbe devrait également
être interdit d'entrer dans le pays
pendant trois ans au terme de cette
séquence polémique novak djokovic
pourrait bien avoir perdu bien plus
qu'un simple tournoi du grand chelem
et l'expulsion de novak djokovic est une
décision injuste pour ses supporters on
écoute certaines réactions un de ses
soutiens
je suis vraiment désabusé par ce système
mais
ce n'est pas ça une démocratie n'est ce
pas un type arrive et prend une décision
après que les tribunaux et statut est un
ministre passe outre et c'est une seule
personne qui prend la décision et ne
sera de 15 à 20 premiers
ces désastres désastreux d'autant plus
qu'il a été invité ici apparemment tous
les documents ont été transmis ont été
enregistrés c'est un vrai cirque après
tout ce qui s'est passé c'est désastreux
en particulier pour les libertés des
gens leur droit de pouvoir s'exprimer
juste le fait de pouvoir s'exprimer ça
me semble injuste
fait
au royaume uni malgré ses excuses devant
les députés mercredi boris johnson reste
dans la tourmente des révélations
concernant de multiples soirées privées
à downing street pendant le confinement
ont tâtonné la popularité du premier
ministre anglais de nombreuses voix
réclament sa démission une situation
compliquée pour boris johnson qui
annonce des mesures pour moraliser son
ministère et faire son mea culpa
sébastien zaba
depuis son accession au pouvoir en 2019
jamais boris johnson n'a été si
fragilisés son autorité est remise en
question par les révélations des soirées
privées organisées au 10 downing street
le premier ministre est poussée de
toutes parts a démissionné du côté de
ses soutiens c'est le coprésident du
parti conservateur oliver dalhunden qui
a volé à son secours en rejetant tous
les appels à sa démission et a souligné
le désir du dirigeant britannique à
racheter ses fautes
je ne minimise pas une seconde la
gravité des événements j'étais en colère
mais électeurs étaient en colère tout le
pays étaient scandalisés et c'est tout à
fait normal que le premier ministre
s'engage à aller au fond des choses je
vous dirais que lorsqu'il répondre à la
chambre des communes comme il s'est
engagé à le faire il s'assurera que nous
nous attaquions en premier lieu à cette
culture de la permissivité
cette culture de la permissivité aurait
favorisé des soirées alcoolisées aux
bureaux du premier ministre alors que le
pays tout entier était confiné il est
question notamment d'une garden party la
veille des funérailles du prince
philippe des écarts de conduite qui ont
scandalisé les britanniques touchés
depuis deux ans par les restrictions
sanitaires comme pour se racheter le
premier ministre a annoncé une série de
mesures parmi lesquelles l'interdiction
de l'alcool dans les bureaux de darwin
street ou encore le licenciement de
plusieurs de ses collaborateurs
malgré tout boris johnson est la risée
de l'opinion publique et de ses
principaux opposants en position de
force pour demander sa démission
[Applaudissements]
ce pays est confronté à d'énormes défis
et nous avons un premier ministre qui
est absent ils se cachent littéralement
en ce moment et il est incapable de
diriger c'est pourquoi j'ai compris
qu'il devait partir bien sûr son départ
serait un avantage pour le parti
travailliste mais en fait c'est
maintenant dans l'intérêt national qui
partent donc c'est très important là que
le parti conservateur fassent le
nécessaire et se débarrasse de lui
un peu plus tôt cette semaine le premier
ministre était appelé à se justifier au
parlement boris johnson a lui présenté
ses excuses des excuses qui n'ont pas
suffi à éteindre un brasier que le
royaume uni appelle désormais le parti
gates
je veux présenter mes excuses
je sais que des millions de personnes à
travers le pays ont fait des sacrifices
extraordinaires durant ces 18 derniers
mois
je suis conscient de leurs inquiétudes
de l'impossibilité de faire le deuil de
leurs proches de vivre leur vie comme
ils le souhaitent et de faire les choses
qu'ils aiment
je comprends la rage qu'ils ressentent à
mon égard à l'égard du gouvernement que
je dirige quand ils pensent qu à downing
street les règles ne sont pas suivies
par les gens qui dicte ses règles
je ne peux pas anticiper les conclusions
de l'enquêté mais j'ai suffisamment
appris pour savoir qu'il y avait des
choses qui ont été mal comprise
et je dois prendre mes responsabilités
[Applaudissements]
des manifestations ont eu lieu ce
week-end dans la capitale londonienne
pour demander la démission du dirigeant
britannique des noms de successeurs
potentiels circulent déjà dans la presse
comme celui de l'actuel ministre des
finances richy sounac de son côté boris
johnson essaie de détourner l'attention
il a annoncé vouloir mettre fin aux
dernières restrictions antico vide en
vigueur dès le 26 janvier prochain
les états unis à présent ou donald trump
était en meeting hier dans l'arizona un
retour au premier plan pour l'ex
président à dix mois de l'élection de mi
mandat et devant ses partisans le leader
des républicains a promis de reconquérir
cette année la chambre le sénat avant la
maison blanche en 2024 juliette a ni
des casquettes rouges et des drapeaux
américains ils étaient plusieurs
milliers à soutenir donald trump ce
samedi à florence un meeting qui
ressemblait étonnamment à ceux organisés
lors de la campagne de 2020
cette année nous allons reprendre la
chambre nous allons reprendre le sénat
nous allons reprendre l'amérique c'est
tellement important et en 2024 nous
allons reprendre la maison blanche
seule différence avec 2020 le slogan
l'ancien président ne veut plus rendre
sa grandeur à l'amérique mais la sauver
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi n'aurait-il pas sur le 3
novembre une élection truquée et voler
sans aller au fond des choses sans quoi
nous n'aurons jamais une démocratie
juste et libre pourquoi ne
s'intéresse-t-il pas cela
si donald trump ne fait pas l'unanimité
dans le pays il bénéficie toujours d'une
forte popularité chez les républicains
il reste le leader incontesté et du côté
des partisans tous n'attend qu'une chose
le retour du milliardaire car beaucoup
d'entre eux estiment que le gouvernement
du dubaï donne n'est pas à la hauteur
je pense que joe biden a échoué dans
tout ce qu'il a dit qu'il allait faire
et je pense qu'il a fait de ce pays un
gâchis il prend trop d'argent et le
donne à d'autres personnes se retire de
l'aghanistan laisse tout notre
équipement là-bas laisse certains de nos
gens là bas puis fait venir des afghans
ici les autorise à entrer dans notre
pays
alors que les élections de mi-mandat
auront lieu en novembre prochain donald
trump qui se tient prêt car cette
échéance cruciale pourrait bien
contrarier l'administration maiden et
envoyé un premier signal en vue de
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 24
donald trump pourrait être encore
beaucoup de pouvoir au sein du parti
républicain selon drieu godefridi
hauteur et docteur en philosophie
l'ex-présidente rome s'inscrit dans une
dynamique je dirais de maintenir une
certaine chaleur dans les relations
entre lui et son et son électorat et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il
continue à organiser ses meetings qui
ont repris assez rapides ont finalement
après l'élection présidentielle en 2002
ordre et est généralement il va dans les
états qui ont qui ont joué joueront dans
l'avenir un rôle crucial au moment de la
prochaine élection présidentielle les
démocrates sont dans une sorte de
politiquement parlant de spirale de mort
haïl sont ils sont ils sont en situation
d'échec finalement total est mis en
échec par des parlementaires démocrates
c'est ça qui rend les chèques d'autant
plus cuisant alors que trump est
effectivement à nouveau dans une haie je
dirais qu'il est dans une position
encore plus fort qu'il ne l'a jamais été
dans le sens où aujourd'hui il contrôle
véritablement l'ensemble voire la
totalité du parti républicain
au mali ibrahim boubacar keïta s'est
éteint à l'âge de 76 ans ce dimanche
l'ancien président élu en 2013 avait
dirigé le pays sept ans avant d'être
renversé par des militaires en août 2020
la junte au pouvoir vient de faire
l'objet de plusieurs sanctions
politiques et économiques par la cedeao
plusieurs pays européens ont aussitôt
suspendu leur aide à bamako les
précisions avec françois xavier lambert
des sanctions exemplaires pour tenter de
faire plier le pouvoir de transition
malien lundi dernier des dirigeants des
pays de la cedeao annonce des mesures
très fortes contre la junte en cause
l'annulation des élections prévues le 27
février prochain et la volonté des
militaires de diriger le pays pendant
cinq années supplémentaires pour les
dirigeants des pays d'afrique de l'ouest
il s'agit d'une atteinte au processus
démocratique
ces sanctions supplémentaires
comprennent le retrait des ambassadeurs
de tous les états membres de la cedeao
au mali deuxièmement la fermeture des
frontières terrestres et aériennes entre
les pays membres de la cedeao et le mali
troisièmement la suspension de toutes
les transactions commerciales et
financières entre les états membres de
la cedeao et le mas des ailes mal mais
ces lourdes sanctions ne font pas
vaciller le chef des forces maliennes
celui qui concentre l'essentiel des
pouvoirs assure vouloir poursuivre le
dialogue diplomatique
et d'ajouter
si nous regrettons l'école accueille est
légitime et légal est inhumé mais
certaines décisions les mâles et reste
ouvert au dialogue avec la cedeao pour
trouver un consensus entre les huit pays
de l'organisation
malgré cette tentative des militaires
d'apaiser la situation
la cedeao a reçu jeudi le soutien des
européens alors que bruxelles avait déjà
suspendu son aide budgétaire à bamako le
chef de la diplomatie européenne a tenu
à rappeler lui souhaiter rester active
au mali mais pas à n'importe quel prix
nous allons suivre de près la situation
et prendre les mesures permanentes
d'appeler les mesures qui ont pris les
voisins africaine de la cedeao nous
serons dans la même ligne de son côté
jean yves le drian a justifié ses
décisions européennes par la nécessité
de contrer toute tentation dictatorial
de la part du pouvoir malien 13 pays ont
pris une position unanime à la fois pour
condamner ce que fait la junte après ces
deux coups d'état et aussi pour prendre
des sanctions pour empêcher le na li de
dériver dans une situation de quasi
dictature
l'union européenne pourrait lever ses
sanctions si les autorités maliennes
accepté de revoir leur calendrier de
transition mais pour l'instant l'armée
malienne ne donne pas de signe en ce
sens vendredi la junte a appelé à
manifester dans tout le pays pour la
soutenir selon le premier ministre par
intérim
bamako va saisir les juridictions
internationales pour contester les
sanctions prises par la cedeao
la situation sécuritaire au mali abordé
avec nous en sarre deuxième vice
président du conseil national de
transition malien l'opération barkan n'a
pas été efficace selon lui
malgré la présence de 3000 un peu plus
de 3000 soldats parfait malgré la
présence de huit
militaires étrangers sur le territoire
maner l'intégrité a bien évité la
situation était à ne s'est pas améliorée
les attentats se sont poursuivies
plusieurs parenté du territoire national
demeure sous contrôle
de forces obscurantistes et on se pose
la question de l'efficacité ou moins de
la pertinence de cette opération mais
comme ce sont les autorités françaises
qui unilatéralement ont décidé de
se retirer ou non d'organiser la fois où
nous nous prenons à créer monde en
tirant en tirant toutes les conséquences
nous allons réorganiser notre pays en
fonction
de ce que
sur le trait
entre l'ukraine et la russie les jours
se suivent mais la tension ne retombe
pas nouveau sujet désormais qui avait
dit avoir des preuves d'une cyber
attaque émanant des russes à son
encontre des accusations fermement
démenties par le kremlin le point avec
notre correspondant à moscou en tolérant
l'ukraine a été ces derniers jours la
cible d'une cyberattaque massive d'après
les autorités
près de 70 sites web de ministères et
agences gouvernementales ont été touchés
dans un premier temps certains
responsables ukrainiens avait écarté la
piste russe avant que kiev mais aussi
washington n'accuse finalement la russie
de ces attaques le tout dans un contexte
de tension extrême entre moscou et kiev
les accusations rejetées en bloc par le
kremlin la russie n'a rien à voir avec
lesdites cyberattaques nous avons
entendu des propos accusant la russie
d'être derrière cela mais aucune preuve
n'a été fournie nous considérons cela
comme la continuation des accusations
sans preuves contre la russie lors de la
semaine qui vient de s'écouler des
représentants russes ont rencontré des
représentants américains de l'otan et de
l'eau et ce afin de discuter de la
situation en ukraine et des garanties de
sécurité demandées par moscou les
progrès ont été minimes et ce nouvel
épisode de tension ces nouvelles
accusations à l'encontre de la russie ne
font qu'ajouter de la pression un statu
quo déjà très précaire et c'est la fin
de ce journal merci d'avoir suivi
prochain point sur l'actualité dans une
trentaine de minutes restez avec nous
sur rt france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres la corruption la profonde
criminalité des états unis et de leurs
alliés de l'otan
ce sa page de réputation qui a commencé
quasiment immédiatement après la
publication des irakiens warlocks
l'isolent de la société
le new york times
le washington post the guardian
der spiegel rigaux
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment 1 je dirais
déçu oui mais pas surpris
[Musique]
l'afrique regorge de richesses mais ne
représentent que 3% du pib mondial en
2021 pourquoi l'afrique hors transports
un petit peu ces matières premières le
problème n'est pas technique c'est un
manque de prise de conscience collectif
des dirigeants africains c'est tout un
ensemble de chaînes des gens qui vont
s'accaparer au pouvoir et la richesse
qui valent la gabégie des hommes d'état
ont l'associent à ce système aussi de la
françafrique la françafrique tout le
monde est au courant maintenant il
s'agit d'un club l'ésotérique de pouvoir
d'argent pour ensemble trouver un
système de rente est par définition de
nombreuses distributions aux populations
il s'agit de venir prendre à la source
quelque chose le problème de fond c'est
curieux c'est la façon dont on le prend
[Musique]
en
bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches une
fois n'est pas coutume je vais féliciter
monsieur macron pour son éclair de
lucidité oui vous nous emmerdez depuis
cinq ans
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ces
caches une émission consacrée cette
semaine aux gros titres de l'actualité
économique au menu donc le variant
omicron et bercy qui renforce ses aides
pour venir en aide aux entreprises on
parlera de cette vague de fusions
acquisitions qui a déferlé en france en
2021 et puis au sommaire un anniversaire
celui de l'euro et qui fête ses 20 ans
on va évoquer à tout cela avec vous
olivier a bien évidemment bonjour liés
bonjour et puis face à vous nathalie
jenson économistes et enseignante
chercheuse à l'école de management neoma
business school bonjour natalie bougeard
sur ce plateau merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation on va commencer à parce
que beaucoup à l'actualité c'est le
variant omicron fin décembre jean castex
a annoncé de nouvelles mesures
restrictives pour tenter d'endiguer
cette vague ainsi les aides pour les
entreprises affectés par les
restrictions sanitaires vont être
renforcé et élargi c'est le cas
notamment dans le secteur du tourisme
avec le grand retour du chômage partiel
sans reste à charge les bases du
déclenchement de ce dispositif sont
élargies et toutes les entreprises qui
auront perdu 60 100 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires contre 80 % jusqu'à présent
pourront en bénéficier
le dispositif de prise en charge des
coûts fixes réservé jusqu'à présent à un
nombre limité d'entreprises sera quant à
lui élargie à l'ensemble des entreprises
du tourisme le seuil d'accès à ce
dispositif est lui aussi abaissé à 50 %
de perte de chiffre d'affaires contre 60
5% auparavant olivier est ce que cela
signifie concrètement que c'est le
retour à une économie sous perfusion a
pas totalement ici il ya quelques il ya
quelques mois quand bruno le maire avait
annoncé la fin ou sonner du quoi qu'il
en coûte et bien un
v rit jaune mais j'avais pris en disant
qu' évidemment le quoi qu'il en coûte ne
s'arrêtait pas est bien la preuve en est
c'est que non seulement il ne s'arrête
pas mais c'est encore j'irai pire
qu'avant et est aujourd'hui on est
obligé à cause des mesures qu'ils
prennent c'est pas le covin n'y est pour
rien là dedans le pauvre petit virus ne
bloque pas l'économie c'est bien il
acquis de nouvelles mesures restrictives
il ya de nouvelles mesures restrictives
d'accord mais c'est justement à cause de
ces nous